Nom de Zeus
ils sont en train de disparaître de la photo
Salut, si on aime bien comprendre les choses,
on est forcément fasciné par la saga de 'Retour vers le futur'
alors c'est mon cas et pour mon anniversaire j'ai eu la chance de recevoir pleins de goodies de la saga.
vous avez pu en voir une partie si vous me suivez sur les réseaux sociaux
Aujourd'hui voici donc quelques anecdotes à savoir sur le film, sur les films
Générique
Alors 'Retour vers le futur' au départ c'était qu'un seul film
et ils ont pris la décision d'en faire une trilogie
au moment où ils ont dû décider de faire un deuxième film
Ça avait eu beaucoup de succès, le public le réclamait
Universal leur a proposé et ils se sont dit OK mais on fait une trilogie
Ce qui était une bonne idée puisqu'au niveau des scénarii
ça permettait de croiser un petit peu les idée du 3ème, du 2ème et les relier au 1er
Tout ce que j'ai écris dans cette vidéo, je l'ai validé dans le livre qui est sorti sur l'histoire de la saga.
C'est un super livre sur toutes les anecdotes autour du livre, sur...
les journées de tournage, une par une
Il a reçu le soutien de Robert Zemeckis et Bob Gale
et il a reçu leur validation également
pour ceux que ça intéresse je met le lien dans la description
Comme dans la plupart des scenarii, il y a eu plusieurs versions
dont 3 scénarios principaux
Et là, il y a quand même pas mal de choses qui changent
Au départ, Doc n'a pas un chien mais un ouistiti
qui deviendra ensuite un chimpanzé
pour dire un moyen global un singe
ce qui sera refusé plus tard
pour devenir dans la version final un chien
Le convecteur temporel, également, qui marche au nucléaire
au départ il marchait également au nucléaire
mais il manquait un ingrédient quelque chose
qui permettait même de s'en passer et surtout de le faire mieux fonctionner
cette ingrédient dans le film c'est Marty qui le découvrira
et c'est du coca
Et dans la toute première version, Marty et Doc devaient partir... *Pchiii*
vers le futur
Pas du tout dans le passé
mais Marty, idée qui va être détourner dans le numéro 2,
a une idée, il se dit "Je vais faire de l'argent avec ça"
et donc il programme la machine à voyager dans le temps pour aller dans un passé proche
pour se donner lui même le résultat des courses hippique et gagner
Mais le vrai grand changement qu'il y a eu de scénario en scénario c'est la fin du film
Au tout début, ça n'avait rien à voir avec l'éclair
Marty et Doc partaient au Nevada pour générer la réaction nucléaire dans un centre d'essai nucléaire.
ce qui fait qu'après Marty dans le futur se retrouvait enseveli sous le sable dans le désert
et encore ce ne sont vraiment que quelques détails que je suis en train de vous donner ici
C'est seulement dans la 2ème version du film,
dans le deuxième scénario que le professeur Emmett Brown va devenir le docteur Brown
Docteur qui sera raccourci en Doc, parce qu'on avait peur à l'époque
qu'on confonde avec la boisson Docteur Pepper
et l'anecdote croustillante que je vous gardais un petit peu pour la fin des versions de scénario
C'est qu'il faudra attendre le 3ème scénario, celui qui a servi de base à la version définitive pour...
voir
que la machine pour voyager dans le temps, la Dolorean
ce n'était pas prévu au départ
c'était censé être une machine à voyager dans le temps
il y a même eu un moment où ça ressemblait plus à un frigo qu'autre chose
mais c'est bien après que c'est devenu une Dolorean
ce qui change tous les scénario possible
puisque dans le 3, par exemple, ils ont des problèmes d'essence
ça c'est directement lié au fait que ce soit une voiture
Saviez vous que Christopher Lloyd, celui qui joue Doc, avait lu le script,
n'était pas très emballé parce qu'il avait des décisions à prendre dans sa vie
puis par rapport au théâtre et ce qu'il allait faire professionnellement
l'endroit où il allait vivre etc...
Il a lu le script et il l'a jeté à la corbeille
ça l'a pas du tout emballé
et c'est sa femme, sa femme de l'époque qui a discuté avec lui
pour lui rappeler quels étaient ces objectifs de départ à lui professionnellement parlant et lui vendre un peu les mérites de ce film
Merci Madame Doc
Mais le plus étonnant c'est que durant les 28 premiers jours de tournage
la personne qui incarnait Marty n'était pas Michael J. Fox
c'était pas encore lui
Non, non, non, non, non
il était beaucoup trop occupé pour incarner le rôle,
parce qu'il tournait déjà à l'époque
et c'est Eric Stoltz, on va dire Eric, qui a endossé le rôle
mais au bout de 28 jours de tournage
quand il fait les pré-montages, Zemeckis n'est pas satisfait du tout du résultat
il trouve que ça ne marche pas
Il pense que le public n'arrivera jamais à s'identifier à lui,
que tous les autres comédiens ça marche, mais que
y a un truc qui se passe pas avec Eric
Il commence à contacter tout le monde pour faire part de ses doutes
et dire "Non il faut que ce soit Michael J.Fox absolument"
Et ils mettent tout un système en place pour contacter son agent,
pour essayer de le convaincre
Et à l'époque comme il tournait comme je vous l'ai dit "Sacré Famille"
Son agent Gary n'avait même pas pris la peine de l'en informer
il avait simplement refuser le projet sans en parler à Michael J. Fox
Gary en parle à Michael J. Fox,
Michael dit "Oui grave j'aimerai trop faire ça"
et son agent lui dit "OK mais va falloir tourner les 2 en même temps. Il est hors de questions que tu arrêtes Sacré famille"
donc durant tout le tournage Michael J. Fox
enchaînait la journée l'un, le soir l'autre
il n'arrêtait jamais.
Ce qui fait qu'il n'a pas vécu pleinement le tournage comme on pourrait s'y attendre
il n'avait pas une vision trop globale de l'histoire
il était toujours déphasé. Et d'après ses dires
c'est ce qu'il lui a aussi permis, dans le rôle
d'avoir ce côté un peu déphasé du mec qui passe d'époque en époque
c'est qu'il le vivait réellement en fait
donc quand il a accepté Zemeckis est aller voir le patron d'Universal
pour essayer de lui dire parce qu'il en avait pas encore parlé à Universal de ça,
qu'il fallait jeter à la poubelle les 28 premiers jours de montage,
pour prendre un nouvel acteur.
Le patron de l'époque leur a juste posé une question
il leur a dit:
"Est ce que vous pensez que ça va changer quelque chose de changer 1 acteur?"
Ils ont dit "Oui"
Le patron a dit Oui
Il n'empêche que dans le 1er film de 'Retour vers le futur'
il reste encore des images avec Eric
qui joue le rôle de Marty. C'est surtout sur des plans larges
mais ça peut se trouver
Tous les détails que je vous raconte ce ne sont que la phase visible de l'iceberg
L'histoire du film telle qu'on le connait aujourd'hui,
avec les acteurs qu'on connait aujourd'hui,
avec les visuels qu'on connait aujourd'hui
est tellement rempli de rebondissement
qu'on pourrait en faire,
un film
Bon c'est une trilogie sur le paradoxe temporel, alors forcément,
il y a pleins d'hypothèses qui ont été faite un peu partout
moi aussi j'ai les miennes, ou des interrogations
ou des choses sur lesquelles on est pas forcément d'accord
parce que déjà, il y a 3 hypothèses.
il y a 3 vraies hypothèses.
Sur la temporalité, le voyage dans le temps, dans tout les films
celle de 'Retour dans le futur' elle s'appuie sur le fait que si on change quelque chose dans le passé
alors le futur change
C'est l'idée de l'effet papillon
Mais, moi il y a des petits détails qui le font pas forcément, surement vous aussi
Parmi les trucs qui me chafouine, il y a, par exemple dans le 2ème film,
quand ils reviennent du futur, de 2015 pour... retourner en 1985
Le 1985 n'est plus le même parce qu'il a changé
par exemple, on apprends que... Doc Brown a été enfermé en 1983
donc si il a été enfermé en 1983, le Marty de 85 du 1er film ne va pas retourner dans le passé
d'ailleurs ça aurait été plutôt malin de la part de Biff de le renfermer
mais d'ailleurs si il est enfermé en 83 et que la machine à voyager dans le temps  n'existe pas.
Ça veut dire que le futur Biff ne pourra pas donner à l'ancien Biff l'almanach
Je sais pas si c'est très clair ce que je dis
mais en clair
puisque Biff
de 2015 a changé
son passé et donc le futur du Biff de 85
tout ce qu'il y a entre 1985 et 2015 n'existent plus
en tout cas plus sous la même forme
et ce qui est sûr c'est que le Biff du futur
n'ira jamais en 85 redonner ça au Biff du passé
alors que c'est une action nécessaire
donc ça, ce sont des petites choses qui peuvent m'empêcher de dormir par exemple
Encore plus grave, le Doc de 85
celui que l'on voit dans le 3ème film,
qui va réparer la Dolorean qui a été laissé depuis le Far West
puisqu'il l'a réparé il connait tout les plans de la machine à voyager dans le temps
il sait comment elle fonctionne,
Pourquoi il va mettre 30 ans à la reconstruire?
maintenant il sait
il a plus besoin de chercher
c'est très simple pour lui
Vous me direz "Oui mais dans ces cas là il y a plus de films"
Oui c'est vrai
mais ça a le droit quand même de me prendre un peu la tête
malgré tout, c'est une saga que j'adore
C'était un grand plaisir pour moi de vous parler un petit peu de 'Retour vers le futur'
même si je pourrais faire une chaîne consacrer à 'Retour vers le futur'
J'adore ça.
Merci d'avoir regarder la vidéo, si elle vous a plu n'hésiter pas à laisser un petit like
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
et puis le Mental Vlog c'est toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an
du 1er janvier au 31 décembre, donc rendez vous demain, on sera lundi, à 17h
Tchao !